l'histoire
au départ les chaussettes
c'est très marrant nous sommes au xvème
siècle pendant la guerre de cent ans la
moitié du territoire français sous
domination anglaise charles 6 10 le roi
folle et schizophrène il souffre de
crises de démence pendant lesquelles il
danse de façon obscène en prétendant
s'appeler georges je trouve pas ça
obscène personnellement oui mais charles
aussi saint fils qui s'appelle charles
vii
les anglais petits filous profite de la
folie du roi pour lui faire signer un
papier disant que son fils est un buteur
un bâtard ne peut pas être roi
mon fils est atteint
bah tu as signé georges et non non vous
vous appelez chat qui a laissé en blanc
on va finir comment ça se danse votre
danse comme ok le fils du roi de france
se retrouve littéralement clodo il est
complètement triste est perdu je
souhaite juste au pardon mais qu'est ce
que c'est que cette voie là c'est quand
je reçois une vive émotion ça ok autant
pour moi c'est là que jeanne débat je
suis jeanne d'arc la pucelle d'orléans
jeu vient prêter main forte à l'héritier
légitime du roi de france pour bouter
les anglais hors de nos frontières et
lui rendre son trône parce que trois
voix avons parlé dans ma tête il faudra
revenir jeudi parce que trois voix avons
parlé dans ma tête
nous sommes les conseillers du roi nous
demandons des preuves
comment peux-tu prouver que tu as bien
entendu les voix que tu dis que tu as
entendu 1-1 et comment pouvez vous
prouver le contraire et partie était
ahurissante
bon admettons et pour le deuxième trou
que tu dis un rapport à la virginité
tout ça quoi
même pas un petit bisou rien de rien
rien de rien je jure bon c'est bien mais
je demande quand même un avis médical
qui est gynécologue ici
c'est à moi que revient cette tâche je
suis le roi
le ca toujours lui ouais ouais ouais nan
mais juste c'est pas poli cette histoire
moi je viens j'ai emprunté un cheval
tout ça je voulais vous aider à plus
manger des racines et au lieu d'être
content vous voulez me ginez colisée je
sais que vous avez pris des habitudes de
clochards mais a des limites et c'est en
remettant tout le monde bien à sa place
ce jour-là que jeanne satire le respect
et la confiance du roi et de ses alliés
elle remporte bon nombre de batailles au
nom du fils du roi et c'est ainsi que se
termine très très très bien l'histoire
de charles sept rois de france
je souris quand un quant à jeanne leroy
la remercia ans ne l'aidant pas du tout
au moment où elle est capturée par les
anglais est brûlée vive à rouen
sérieusement à rouen en tout cas d'après
des chaussettes papin
pain d'un pin pin pin pas papin game of
thrones